well your day
you know him thomas has an adopted son
in his person
it would be a question of taking into consideration
the efforts of this boy who travels more
than two hours a day to
come to study here so i proposed that
tom come to our house  for the moment
to help work in my
anyway he never sees coming here
what should first of all therefore there because
he hates
it may be harassment
which is much more serious
how that it is not  the first time
why are you beating like that all the
games we don't like each other / I
it seems that you haven't defended yourself
the concern that a man feels in
himself by the absence of something that
would give me pleasure if they were
present
that's what we call desire
you didn't trust amiens
tian homeless in others in life